[Music]
foreign
[Music]
strains of a Piper's lament they
gathered to bury their dead
49 year old Martin McGill was Scottish
but had moved to Ireland to care for his
elderly mother
[Music]
they lined the street outside Saint
Michael's Church a Paris United in
prayer for those laying loved ones to
rest
[Music]
the funeral of Jessica Gallagher had
taken place earlier the 24 year old had
a promising career in design ahead of
her everyone who knew Jessica knew that
radiant smile
that radiant smile that would light up
her room what that infectious warmth
that flowed from her
two teenagers and a five-year-old girl
were among 10 people killed in a
suspected gas explosion at this petrol
station it's had a devastating impact on
this small isolated community
it's like
watching a film
and the film has gone very bad and very
sad and you just want to press a button
on your remote control to change the
channel or to switch off that film
but unfortunately
for those who have lost loved ones and
they cannot switch off that film
all 10 funerals will have taken place
before they even begin to comprehend how
something so awful could have happened
here in this Village by the deep lake
signified by its Irish name Krishna
there is a deep sense of grief but it's
matched by the sense of community as
people come together to stand with those
who've lost so much
foreign
they've been comforted by messages of
condolence from Pope Francis and King
Charles
but life in this remote corner of
Ireland will never be the same again
David Blevins Sky News at Chrysler in
County Donegal